tenemos el siguiente problema dice un
mesero sirvió una taza de café
la temperatura inicial del café era de
90 grados celsius a medida de que pasa
el tiempo temp la temperatura del café
se empezó a decrecer exponencialmente y
acercarse a la temperatura ambiente de
20 grados celsius cuál de las siguientes
graficas modela esta relación muy bien y
tenemos 1234 gráficas y lo primero que
podemos ver es que la temperatura
inicial del capem es del 90 grados
celsius así que bueno todas empiezan el
90 grados celsius las 4 empiezan en ese
valor pero después nos dicen a medida
que pasa el tiempo tema la temperatura
del café empezó a decrecer
exponencialmente y acercarse a la
temperatura ambiente de 20 grados
celsius
así que si observas esta gráfica amd si
tiende conforme pasa el tiempo a la
temperatura de 20 grados celsius aquí en
mi inciso b puedes observar que no
tiende a 20 grados celsius de hecho en
el tiempo te iguala 70 minutos supongo
la temperatura va a ser de 0 grados
celsius y eso no tiene sentido así que
con esto podríamos descartar el inciso b
o inclusive nos podríamos dar cuenta de
que este es un modelo lineal y por lo
tanto no nos sirve ahora si nos fijamos
en el inciso se puedes ver que aquí
tenemos un estado final de 20 grados
celsius pero observa este no parece un
modelo exponencial parece un modelo
lineal y justo cuando llegamos a 50
minutos se mantiene constante en la
temperatura de 20 grados celsius así que
no es un decrecimiento exponencial
entonces es sencillo hacer también lo
podemos descartar y bueno hasta ahorita
va bien el inciso am pero por último
vamos a ver el inciso de este también es
un decrecimiento exponencial su
temperatura inicial es de 90 grados y
bueno cuando empieza a decrecer de
manera exponencial va a tender a algo
que no es la temperatura ambiente si
observas tiende a 30 grados celsius que
no son los 20 grados celsius que
buscábamos así que solamente por eso
vamos a descartar también el inciso de y
ahora sí podemos seleccionar al inciso a
como la respuesta correcta es un modelo
que te crece exponencialmente tiene una
temperatura inicial de 90 grados celsius
y tiende conforme pasa el tiempo a la
temperatura ambiente de 20 grados
celsius así que vamos a comprobar
nuestra respuesta de lujo estamos bien y
vamos a hacer un problema más bien es
este de aquí dice desde que cerraron las
fábricas la población de una ciudad
empieza a decrecer exponencialmente la
siguiente gráfica representa a la
población ven en miles de años desde que
cerraron las fábricas y si observas aquí
tenemos esta gráfica de aquí y puedes
ver que cuando el tiempo valía cero la
población era de 40.000 habitantes y
después esta población va decreciendo y
parece que tiende
la mente hacia 20.000 habitantes así que
veamos que nos preguntan basándose en la
gráfica desde que cerraron las fábricas
a que tiende la población a medida que
pasa el tiempo ok
bueno justo lo acabamos de decir la
población tiende mientras va pasando el
tiempo al valor de 20.000 al valor de
20.000 habitantes observa cómo va
atendiendo a este valor así que
tendríamos que seleccionar esta opción
si observamos 22 mil sería un buen valor
para aproximarnos no sé aquí cuando
teníamos de 20 a 22 años porque 22 mil
queda por aquí pero a la larga todo
tiende a 20.000 y bueno 30.000 y 40.000
son valores más grandes así que la
población va a atender a medida que pasa
el tiempo al valor de 20.000 comprobemos
nuestra respuesta y de lujo estamos bien